this following DVD shows each of the
four project and will give you an idea
of the exciting activities that have
been happening across the district
so if the big loss real projects are run
by TP teen birds play network money from
the National Lottery pays for free play
in the park sessions these sessions help
children and their parents overcome
barriers through playing in the local
park and we hope encourage them to use
this area the town and parish council
work in the partnership with TP to
liaised with members of the local
community in developing ideas on the
type of activities they would like in
their Park the activities are chosen
after the parish council has consulted
with the local children this session
shows the children being creative and
making dream catchers
the second project play Rangers were set
up through work with children so that
they can play freely in a safe
environment the play rangers provide an
adult presence in the park enabling the
children to play the children decided
what activities they would like to do
and the Rangers help them make it happen
over the three years of the lottery
funding so play Rangers will go into
four parks providing weekly sessions you
are watching the rangers in action 7
hi I'm Robin and one of the play ranges
here and we've come to Sandringham park
today to do some activities with the
children I think where they want to do
some a game called manhunt which is a
game of hide-and-seek they're gonna do
and we should be having lots of fun
we're here every monday from 3pm to six
o'clock rain or shine and it should be a
lot of fun today i show here we gonna
use the woods yeah
so you don't see or your own have a
friend then they come and you play for
Allah that fast and two o'clock
trunki hand up around there the girls
activity project works with the youth
service and was set up to meet the needs
of girls between age of 11 and 1660
sessions will be offered over the three
years during school holidays and
evenings there will also be to
residential weekends the workshop
leaders help young people to develop
their skills this particular session was
filmed in chudley youth center there are
lots of other sessions on offer such as
nail art of defense
the environmental play spaces project
lets children create their own place
features this project will go into six
locations working with local children's
create a play space you can see here a
semi-permanent den built from Willow
this was built by children and adults in
ashburton community garden local
children were involved in a consultation
exercise to find out what they would
like in the community garden part of the
big lottery funded projects is about
encouraging children and families back
into the parks are letting them play and
letting them enjoy their surrounding
areas three sessions followed the
building of the weather dome while
Willow was used to create bow and arrows
and in patches